all right hey take a look behind us here
and chant is ready for you out at the
Las Vegas ballpark ice
ice skate treats drinks so much more out
there it'll just be amazed if you didn't
visit last year this may be your year
and Candace Charles joins us live from
the ballpark she's just a little
snowflake trying to find a place to land
good morning
you look adorable
that was perfect good morning to you
guys good morning folks right now I am
on the ice skating Trail in inside of
the middle of the maze the maze is a
really really cool part I'm not gonna
lie guys I'm a little nervous because
usually I'm used to having like someone
that is amazing at skating on the X with
me but it's okay I'm doing my little
dance moves you can come out here and do
the same with your family and enjoy the
entire experience besides the maze which
is really cool and stuff like I said you
can go around the maze find the missing
toys and possibly get your chance to
land in the Hallmark movies and find all
those toys bring up your passport and
mail it get a chance to win getting
inside of the Hallmark movie besides
that you can enjoy some of the stages
here there's live music of course as I
mentioned ice skating rig there's a
dance floor over there there's a bar a
little bit of everything for everyone
and you get a chance to also give back
to some local small businesses there's
some small business shops right on top
of here giving everything away from like
little hats and little treats of course
there's snacks here so this is a fun
filled Christmas holiday experience for
the whole entire family or a special
date night now I'm gonna try to move a
little bit because I said that I would
and I want to do this for you John
really see look I got it guys I got it
guys
is starting this Wednesday every
Wednesday to Sunday all the way to the
18th the 19th of the first it's every
single day on Wednesdays you can bring
your kids for free and if you want to
come late like a late night owl you can
come the last two hours for just 25
bucks 34 regular time and 20 bucks for
just your children of course we have all
details for you on your website
igneouslap.com all right guys I'm
staying in the way
you're bad you're not going to make much
progress getting around the rink like
that Candace you're going to be there
alone this is the safest option though
and I'm wondering about her photographer
is that Armando or Stacy on Skate so I'm
guessing they're showing her shoes yeah
hey
he's actually
he's very good he's very good he has his
candles going on all right well let him
grab your hand and pull you around
can practice during the commercial break
all right I can't just have fun out
there be careful